Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus und es ist das hundertste
Mal dass ich das sage wir machen heute
die 100 die Ausgabe unseres Podcasts es
kommt einem PUKY vor also da freue mich
darüber ich finde es schön ich freue
mich auch darüber aber es kommt mir
nicht wie 100 vor
also wirklich über 100 verschiedene
Themen miteinander geredet haben in zwei
Jahren ist schon unvorstellbar und ich
muss ehrlich sagen einfach ganz wie soll
man sagen
demütig jetzt an dem Punkt das war aus
dem Stand sehr erfolgreich
ich habe mich sehr darüber gefreut und
mehr noch freue ich mich aber darüber
dass diese Gespräche der Austausch mit
dir der hat mich in meiner anderen
Arbeit noch einmal enorm weitergebracht
also es ist wirklich so also ich glaube
es gibt keinen Freund den ich habe mit
dem ich sonst irgendwo zusammenkomme
hier zu trinken mit dem ich wieder
solche Ausführlichkeit solche Frequenz
ja nicht nur über das Weltgeschehen
unterhalte sondern natürlich indirekt
auch immer über die eigene
Befindlichkeit ja also wir erörtern ja
nicht nur sagt Themen sondern das was
uns gerade wichtig ist hängt natürlich
auch immer mit wenn man sich gerade
fühlt das ein gerade gefangen nimmt und
so weiter und das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig dass man ja irgendwie
beruflich oder so ein intensiven
Austausch miteinander genau und schön
ist zu sehen und das ist ja das was ist
dann am Ende auch macht das geht für
mich lange schon weit über den Beruf
hinaus
ja das ist das fühlt sich ja nicht wie
Beruf an Gott fühlt sich auch nicht viel
Arbeit an richtig na ich glaube dann
würden wir sofort damit aufhören wenn es
sich viel Arbeit angenommen wurde genau
aber es wirklich ist bereichert
tatsächlich mein Leben ja
das freut mich dass meine ich ganz
ehrlich und ganz aufrichtig und ich
danke dafür an dem Punkt und ich habe
ihn danke ich habe mir überlegt Richard
es ist ein Sommer der an vielen Punkten
dazu andere mal ein bisschen
nachzudenken und es gab so Entwicklungen
in diesem ersten halben Jahr von denen
ich geahnt habe dass sie auf Deutschland
zukommen würden wir beide haben uns
häufiger darüber unterhalten 2016 war
für mich so ein Moment als wir damals
die erste Amerika Reportage gemacht
haben Amerika ungeschminkt das war das
war wie ein Erweckungserlebnis aber der
negativen Art und wirklich einen Schlag
ins Gesicht weil plötzlich die
Utopie und darüber wollte ich heute
gerne mal mit dir sprechen im Raum stand
das Donald Trump Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika werden
könnte und es war egal wie diese Wahl
ausgehen würde klar da verschieben sich
gerade Dinge und es ist ein Lebensgefühl
in mein Leben und ich glaube auch in das
Leben viele andere gekommen von dem ich
sagen würde dass verschiebt sich auch
immer mehr in Richtung Deutschland
dieses Gefühl dass man vorher irgendwie
nicht hatte in meiner Kindheit in meiner
Jugend war immer die Idee es geht
irgendwie nach vorne wir machen weiter
wir haben eine Idee und vielleicht ist
es manchmal nicht Spinne hat der Idee
aber wie werden irgendwie die Welt
erobern und heute ist das Gefühl und das
betrübt mich richtig dagegen Anti wir
wollen nichts mehr wir sind von Beruf
nur noch dagegen geht es auch so ja wir
können keinen leiden wir sind über alles
gereizt wir sind über dagegen das ist
eigentlich die Stimmung genau aber
ja hast du dieses Gefühl
jeder nervt ja genau
jetzt kann man ja sagen guck mal wenn
man sich die welthistorische Situation
anguckt in der wir uns befinden dann ist
die gar nicht so wie wir das gerade
beschrieben haben so kleinen gereizt und
nicht sondern die eigentliche Situation
die wir uns befinden sind drei große
gigantische Revolutionen ereignen sich
gleichzeitig was ist noch nie in der
Geschichte der Menschheit gab und global
was ist auch noch nie gab das heißt also
wir haben
den Anfang der multipolaren Weltordnung
durch den Aufstieg Asiens also das lange
stabile Gefüge der USA als hier im
mundial Macht der Welt das wird in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten verloren gehen und
davon merken wir jetzt schon ganz ganz
viel dass das so ist das zweite was ich
verändert durch die digitale Revolution
ja wird sich nicht nur unsere Art zu
wirtschaften verändern mit all diesen
Auswirkungen Arbeitsmarkt wo wir darüber
gesprochen haben sondern es wird wieder
um die ganze Gesellschaft gewürfelt als
die erste illustrielle Revolution das
erste Maschinenzeitalter begann als
Agrargesellschaften sich eine
Industriegesellschaften verwandelt hat
und das war der Beginn des bürgerlichen
Zeitalters war das Ende der Herrschaft
von Adel und Kirche riesige Veränderung
neues Betriebssystem von Gesellschaft
bürgerliche Lohnarbeit und
Leistungsgesellschaft jetzt kommt das
zweite Maschinenzeitalter und wir haben
gar keine Ahnung was kommt denn jetzt
für eine Gesellschaft das ist denn das
eine ki-gesellschaft die muss man sich
das vorstellen wie wird die Welt in im
Zeitalter selbst Lernender Maschinen
überhaupt sein wir haben keine
Vorstellung wir haben viele Ängste die
sich damit verbinden einige haben
Geschäftsordnungen aber alles in allem
mulmiges Gefühl ja verändert sich ganz
viel und der Unterschied zur ersten
industriellen Revolution war damals
konnte man sagen Adelsgesellschaft war
auch für 90% der Menschen die nie
erlebten ziemlich übel so ne also man
hatte viel zu gewinnen heute hat man
eher das Gefühl wenn sie jetzt um die
ganze Gesellschaft gepokert und
gewürfelt wird und sich ganz ganz viel
verändert wir haben so unglaublich viel
zu verlieren genau
uns jetzt auch genau das ja und das
dritte ist dann noch die die
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ja also wir
die ersten beiden Fragen werden ziemlich
unwichtig sein wenn wir es nicht
schaffen
die die katastrophale Situation in die
wir die Menschheit ob ich den Planeten
aber die Menschheit auf dem Planeten
gebracht haben ja also nicht nur der
Klimawandel auch die Ressourcen
Verschwendung die wir da betreiben die
die Meere die Kippen und alles was dazu
gehört das heißt wir sind also kurz
davor ja diesen Planeten zu verlassen es
ist kein wirklich unwahrscheinliches
Szenario zu sagen 150 Jahren kann auf
der Erde können Menschen nicht mehr
unter normalen Bedingungen leben das ist
durchaus denkbar also wir könnten
tatsächlich die letzte oder vorletzte
Generation sein und wenn man das drei
zusammenbringt also die Apokalypse ja
die ökologische Apokalypse sozusagen
dann diese enorme karnevalisierung
unserer Gesellschaft und jetzt
karnevalisierung nicht nur im positiven
Sinn als ich meine ummaßierung
ungrapierung von allem ja die
stattfindet durch das zweite
Maschinenseite und dann auch noch die
geopolitischen Auseinandersetzung im
Zuge eines gigantischen umflügens das
macht Gefüges in der Welt
wundert man sich dann darüber dass so
viele Leute sich in ihr Klinken und
sagen ihr geht mir alle nur noch auf dem
Sack
vielleicht ist eine ganz normale
Reaktion ja das glaube ich auch vor
allen Dingen ich habe mich vor einiger
Zeit mit Jürgen Schmidhuber beschäftigt
den du auch kennst ja ki-pionier der
ersten Stunde der München tu und der
Sprachform miraculösen Jahr 1990/91 wo
die wirklich angefangen haben so
richtige Grundlagenforschung zu machen
und die Tatsache dass dein Telefon heute
reagiert wenn du mit ihm sprichst geht
unter anderem auf die Arbeit von Jungs
mit Huber und unseren Studenten zurück
und noch einigen anderen und er er hat
das Ding noch mal in den Schmid Hubers
Thema ist ja der ganz große Horizont und
er sagte pass auf unsere Erde
14,5 bis 15 Milliarden Jahre ja alt
richtig alt so aber so richtig die Post
abgegangen ist sozusagen auf den
allerletzten Metern über die jetzt
gerade sprechen das heißt sozusagen der
der Unterschied zwischen dem Typen der
das erste mal auf die Idee kam er
irgendeinen Flug hinter einem Ochsen zu
spannen ja und den Typen der jetzt
darüber nachdenkt maximal viele
Transistoren auf einen winzigen kleinen
Computerchip draufzupacken 10.000 Jahre
das ist nicht das ist gar nicht und dann
muss man auch sagen also die neolitische
Revolution
Diät machen machen wir uns falsch also
dem geht's eigentlich bergab
natürlich kulturgeschichtlich bergauf
und dann muss man mal sehen von von
Ackerbau und Viehzucht angefangen bis
zur ersten industriellen Revolution
Vergehen jetzt erstmal 10000 Jahre in
denen die Lebensqualität eines
Durchschnittsmenschen sich nicht
verbessert so das heißt auch ein Bauer
im alten Rom hat ähnlich gelebt wie ein
Bauer in Westfalen gemacht ja die
gleiche Lebenserwartung keine
vernünftige Medizin keine Rente und
genau gar nichts und die ganze
Entwicklung über die wir jetzt reden das
sind 200 ja genau das genau darauf weist
er auch hin und ich du kennst das ja von
saß man der der Anthropologen ja immer
sagt der den steinzeitlichen Jäger den
musste man sich eigentlich aus einem
relativ entspannten Menschen vorstellen
seine Theorie der geht halt raus wenn er
was zum Essen braucht zu jagt oder wären
sammeln was auch immer der Stress kam in
die Bude als wir angefangen haben Acker
bauen viel zu tun haben die Kriege kam
da also einer der der
faszinierendsten Gesprächspartner die
ich hier gehabt habe ist in Schweizer
Anthropologe okay klingt der hat so ein
dickes Buch geschrieben tribale Kriege
Stammes Kriege Stammes kriegen und damit
beschäftigt er sich und sagt seit wann
gibt es Kriege wieso gibt es Kriege
wodurch entstehen Kriege und er sagt
dass indigene Völker früher keine Kriege
geführt hat
das heißt sie haben es gab natürlich gab
es Vergewaltigung natürlich gab es Morde
ja natürlich hat man den anderen mal
hier was überfallen und da was
weggenommen aber Krieg im Sinne von
geplant organisiert von langer Hand
vorbereitet und so weiter hat es nicht
gegeben weil der Preis des Krieges immer
höher ist als ich aus dem Weg zu gehen
das heißt die klassische Nomadenvölker
ja im wussten genau du hast durch den
Krieg immer mehr zu verlieren als du zu
gewinnen hast mit der Sesshaftigkeit
konntest du nicht mehr ausweichen
richtig ja wenn du da zehn Jahre dein
Acker über Krankheit hast und jetzt die
Früchte deines Erfolgs und das erste was
passiert ist jemand anders nimmt dir das
weg dann gehst du nicht einfach weg
sondern du verteidigst deine Scholle
also mit der Sesshaftigkeit kommt doch
der Krieg in die Welt das interessante
ich meine da hast du auch die Antwort
auf die Frage warum die Ukrainer sich
gerade so wäre gegen diesen Putin ja
ausweichen geht ja nicht nein du kannst
nicht ausweichen nein du kannst nicht
sondern Du musst Dich dem stellen und es
ist und da geht es genau darum ne du
bist ein bisschen im Grunde genommen
in der Grenze zweier zweier Machtblöcke
das ist ja das ich meine die Ukraine
hatte das Tragische Pech sozusagen an
der an der Naht an der Schnittstelle ja
so plattentektonisch ist das der Punkt
wenn wo die beiden Platten aufeinander
knallen die asiatischer auf die
europäische und die Vulkane ausbrechen
ja also es gibt die westliche
machthemisphäre und es gibt die
russische machte es wäre und hier geht
sozusagen aus bei sich beider Länder ja
hier gibt's keinen Schritt mehr nach
Dings und das endet im Stellungskriegen
nordeuropäische tief Ebene ja besser
genau aber wenn wir Utopien reden würden
wir natürlich gerne über eine Welt reden
wo wir sagen wollten geschaffen wir das
im 21 Jahrhundert die Kriege loszuwerfen
das ist das Dinge das Lebensgefühl für
mich und offenkundig auch für dich und
ich glaube für viele viele da draußen im
Moment ist nämlich genau das jetzt
stehen wir hier in diesem Sommer und und
freuen uns auch dass endlich mal wieder
Sommer ist und so weiter und eigentlich
sollte doch alles leicht und schön sein
aber nichts ist leichter schön und dann
kriegst du mit wie wir eigentlich alle
nur noch die ganze Zeit und das passiert
eben auch politisch erklären was alles
nicht geht und wir haben uns ja schon
einige Male über die AFD unterhalten das
ist das eine aber was ich viel wirklich
viel deprimierender finde als ständig
über diese Stöckchen der AFD zu springen
ist für mich dass die anderen
offenkundig auch nicht mehr Willen sind
etwas zu gestalten eine Utopie zu
entwerfen sondern kommt die CDU die FDP
ist völlig richtig also aufpassenden
Verbrenner müssen wir wirklich statt
wirklich hinzugehen und zu sagen lass
uns doch jetzt mal gemeinsam überlegen
wo ist die große
Utopie
wenn wir etwas verändern will ja das
gestalten will der sucht sich Ziele so
ja und etwas verhindern will der sucht
Gründe und wir erleben eine Diktatur der
Gründe über die Ziele
das heißt also wenn irgendjemand mit
irgendeiner abweichen Idee sagen wir
können nicht mal diese Richtung denken
oder sollte man das anders machen dann
kommt die Bedenkenträger mit schweren
Panzern angerollt und Palmen in den
nieder
nicht gesagt auch in den Medien ja jeder
Freude sich da ist eine ein kleinen
Schritt von dem Weg seiner Partei oder
sowas abgegangen ne das muss jetzt
sofort angeprangert werden und so weiter
und dann gibt's die bedingten Träger
eine eigene Partei die ihn doch wieder
zurückfallen aber weißt du schon oft
zitiert ne aber ich finde es ist dass
das drückt die Situation eigentlich am
besten aus ne das ist dieses Zitat von
Sergio Leone und dem großen Italo
Western Regisseur der Regisseur von
spiel mir das Lied mal gefragt wurde was
ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen
einem Italo Western und einem
amerikanischen Western der sagt wenn bei
John Ford ja großer amerikanischer
Western Regisseur jemand aus dem Fenster
guckt dann hat er den Blick in eine
strahlende Zukunft und wenn bei mir eine
aus dem Fenster guckt dann weiß jeder
der wird jetzt erschossen und so geht es
mit Utopien heute die Fensterläden
auflegen ja und ein Blick in eine
strahlende Zukunft zeigt
erschossen ja und weißt du was das
Bittere daran ist
alle wissen das und es ist ja nicht so
dass in der CDU oder auch in der FDP
oder auch in allen anderen Parteien da
sind doch gute Leute es ist es wäre so
billig und so einfach zu sagen der die
haben alle keinen Plan und die wollen
alle nichts und die wollen nur Wahlen
hier nicht schlechter als die Leute die
an ihn rumnörgeln das meine ich drücken
das doch einfach mal so genau
Pfeifen der Republik alle in der Politik
alles
diese kritisieren sind
sondern da sind gute Leute und die sind
überall das sind nicht nur gute Leute
sind sie genau so wie der Rest der
Gesellschaft das würde ich genauso sagen
sie sind ein gutes Spiegelbild oder gute
Repräsentanten der Gesellschaft genau
was ja die Frage aufwirft und medial
übrigens das gleiche ja also wenn wenn
sozusagen jemand ist irgendwie sehr gut
sehen ne in den vergangenen Monaten alle
sind der Meinung es muss etwas geschehen
ja aber wenn dann etwas geschieht immer
das falsch gemacht
genau und die selben Leute die vorher
sozusagen nur noch beklatscht haben dass
dieser Mann erkennbar sich traut in den
Wind zu stellen und und auch mal eine
möglicherweise eine wärmewende wirklich
anzufassen sind dieselben Leute okay ja
aber bitte doch nicht so so geht das
nicht das heißt wir alle haben irgendwie
ein Problem sozusagen konstruktiv nach
vorne zu gucken dann schauen die ganze
Zeit nur destruktiv auf das was nicht
geht und ich denke so oft an Alexander
gauland der mir meine Sendung sagte
resortiment ist kein Programm
bin mir da nicht mehr sicher ne würde
ich auch sagen
zukunftsvollste Programm im Augenblick
in der Politik geht nicht wollen wir
nicht brauchen wir nicht ja also wer
gegen etwas ist macht sich nicht
angreifbar ist der Punkt wäre aber für
etwas ist sogar ich meine wir sind
überall als die Gesellschaft ja und wenn
man diesen diesen Theorien glauben kann
dass Europa zum Sterben verurteilt ist
ja weil es zu alt ist weil es zu träge
ist und so weiter ich will das jetzt
nicht eins zu eins zu übernehmen aber
dieses Bild mal bedienen dann dürfen wir
uns nicht Wunder ja dass wir eine
Republik der Nörgeler der Verhinderer
und so weiter geworden du meinst es ist
die alte sack-wertung die da gerade
schon zu besichtigen ist ja es stimmt
wahrscheinlich deswegen nicht weil große
Teile der Jugend sind zum Teil
konservativer als über 60-Jährigen es
ist ja glaube ich keine reine
Altersfrage das ist glaube ich ja aber
man kann das ist vielleicht nicht rein
demografisch aber es ist eine
sattelgesellschaft die zu recht viel zu
verlieren hat und die wie alle die viel
zu verlieren hat das Hauptaugenmerk auf
Besitzstandswahrung und ich auf
Veränderung liegt und die Angst
eigentlich vor Veränderung hatte unsere
Gesellschaft hat Angst vor Veränderungen
weil sie viel zu verlieren hat und da
entsteht relativ wenig politische
Dynamik und ich meine die Dinge also
heizungsgesetz und was ist denn jetzt
nicht die die Riesen Revolution und was
weiß ich das ist alles Experten sind
sich einig es ist viel viel zu wenig und
nicht mal dieses viel zu wenig lässt
sich realisieren
also das
implizite
angeguckt weißt du wann dieses
skandinavischen Länder angefangen haben
wirklich systematisch auf Wärmepumpen
also noch früher als Angela merkelenz
ankam
2005 ging so richtig los und seitdem
immer weiters können und wenn du dir
sozusagen die guten Geschichten mal
anschaust wir sind doch eigentlich eine
Gesellschaft mit unglaublichen Chancen
ich habe neulich eine total
beeindruckende Tage gelesen die
Durchschnitts des Durchschnitts Mädchen
das heute auf die Welt kommt in
Deutschland wird 84 Jahre alt und nicht
nur das wir gewinnen jede Woche ein
Wochenende
Lebenserwartung dazu überleg mal wann
war das mal so in der Geschichte der
Menschheit gab mal größere Sprünge
definiert haben noch nie wie heute also
die Versprechen die Versprechen der
zaubermedizin der Zukunft sind enorm so
ja und selbst wenn vieles am Ende an
Kündigung bleibt Essen große
medizinische Fortschritte zu erwarten
alles andere würde mich sehr überraschen
wenn das nicht so wäre das heißt also
ein quantitativ
kriegen wir da ja schon mal eine ganze
Menge hin Messi die Frage wird nur sein
wie qualitativ schön wird das Leben
eines Mädchen sein dass jetzt geboren
wird wie wird die Welt in 50 70 oder 80
Jahren aussehen so und jetzt kann man
die gute Nachricht ist es liegt ja in
unserer Hand also die Zukunft wird ja
gemacht
ja aber gestalten
Politik ist heute sehr sehr weitgehend
Verwaltung weil die
Gestaltungsspielräume so klein sind und
zwar in Kleinen wie im Großen man könnte
ja schon im Kleinen damit anfangen also
wenn man jetzt irgendein Großprojekt
oder sowas plant dann weiß man in
Deutschland gibt es drei Verfahrenswege
so drei Stufen ja und man kann also
Sachen über zehn Jahre blockieren bis
sie irgendwann realisiert wird warum
verkürzen wir das nicht endlich mal also
ein großes strukturprojekt steht an alle
Bevölkerung mit reinholen die sich daran
beteiligen wollen aber dann nur noch ein
revisionsweg und nicht dass man da noch
geht und hier noch und
Verwaltungsgericht und so weiter also
dieses ausbremsen auf dem juristischen
Wege das ist auch ein ganz anderes
Beispiel ich habe mich ja mal damit
beschäftigt wenn man die Schulen
zukunftstauglicher machen kann und ich
habe in dem Zusammenhang schon lange her
die Grundschullehrerin meines Sohnes das
siehst du wie lange das hier ist jetzt
20 gefragt warum der Biologieunterricht
Thema Blätter
ja warum der auf Arbeitsblättern
stattfindet und nicht mit realen
Blättern im Wald und da sagt sie sieht
zu mir ja das geht nicht das geht nicht
weil dann brauche ich eine juristische
aussichtsperson ja also wenn ich hier
auch jemand da ist der die Kinder es
könnte ja ein asthmoment fallen und ich
bin alleine mit 25 Kindern im Wald ja
das sieht der Gesetzgeber so nicht vor
und ich dachte wenn schon auf so einer
Mikro Ebene überhaupt keine
Handlungsspielräume mal irgendetwas
anders wenn das natürlich jetzt ein ganz
kleines Beispiel schon klar aber das
zieht sich natürlich bisschen die ganz
großen Dinge rein ich habe ein großes
Beispiel für dich hat wenn du oder
anders gefragt brauchen wir sozusagen
diesen dieses Schock Erlebnis dass uns
dann aufrüttelt frage ich mich manchmal
so ähnlich wie es z.B für die Amerikaner
war als plötzlich Sputnik ja im Weltraum
[Musik]
was dann dazu geführt hat das Kennedy
sagte okay zum Ende des Jahrzehnts sind
wir auf dem Mond ja und alle haben
gelacht also wahrscheinlich viele
Bedenken auch hierzulande und am Ende
hat es funktioniert am Ende standen
Menschen auf dem Mond aber wie kann das
sein dass wesentliche
Grundlagenforschung zum Thema KI du hast
mit gerade erwähnt im deutschsprachigen
Raum geleistet wurde ja und da so wenig
Geschäftsmodelle raus entstanden sind
warum gibt es nur zwei Länder in der
Welt die im Grunde genommen von ganz
kleinen Nischen mal abgesehen den
gesamten ki-markt und so weiter
beherrscht die ganze Digitalisierung in
der Hand haben das sind die USA und
China warum ist Deutschland überhaupt
kein ernst zu nehmen der Player in
dieser ganzen Geschichte was ist da
alles schief gelaufen auf dem Weg dahin
das ist die große Frage Beispiel
Frauenhofer Institut ne ich habe mal
wesentlich den MP3 Player entwickelt ja
MP3 und ich glaube die kriegen alle
Jahre immer noch
Tantiemen für für Patent und so weiter
ein paar zehn Millionen vielleicht sind
sie 100 Millionen ich habe keine Ahnung
auf jeden Fall Geld und steht dann in
diesem Geschäftsbericht und so weiter
und da ist man stolz drauf aber es
überleg dir mal was Apple aus dieser
Technologie gemacht hat die haben damit
Milliarden der Unterschied ist einfach
am Ende gewinnt der der die meisten
Investoren ansieht also die größten es
ist jetzt der skalierungseffekt und
diese diese Weltmachtstellung die ist
nur zu erreichen indem du irrsinnig
große Kapitalgeber findest und das
funktioniert in den USA anders als bei
uns ja also weil das Kapital der Welt
quasi gewöhnt ist an einem Ort wie beim
Silicon Valley zu investieren und dort
informieren haben die diese enorme
Möglichkeit neue Produkte mit einer
irrsinnigen macht und einer Breite so
skalierungseffekt auf dem Markt zu
bringen was ist Deutschland so nicht
hinkriegt und wir haben keinen
europäische vergleichbaren Kapital Pool
oder sowas oder eine ähnliche Struktur
aufbauen oder schaffen kann ne ich
glaube das ist der Hauptgrund also bei
uns fehlt ein Geld aber wenn das mal
anschaust die die Land ökologisch stärkt
der Fortschritt der Computer der
Menschen zum Mond gebracht hat der war
hunderttausendmal Leistungsschwäche als
ein Prozessor heute in einem iPhone ja
ein iPhone hat hunderttausendmal mehr
Prozessorleistung ja jetzt musst du dir
mal vorstellen ist unvorstellbar dafür
haben sich Menschen auf auf sozusagen
auf auf die auf den Höllentrip ihres
Lebens eingelassen ja und wie gesagt
okay egal da gibt es ein sehr hohes
Risiko und wenn der Rechner einmal
abläuft dann haben wir ein Problem das
gesamte Risiko dieser dieser Mondlandung
war so enorm richtig ja die
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht zurückzukommen
so und dieser Schock das meine ich der
hat dazu geführt dass plötzlich
technologische riesensprunge ja möglich
waren
dann könnte man ja sagen Aldi die großen
Erfindungen und so weiter können ja auch
ein Schock auslösen
aber was in erster Linie aus ist eine
andere Art von Schock das ist eine Angst
vor einer Zukunft wo man sich sagte weil
will ich eigentlich irgendwann nicht
mehr drin vorkommen ich will so einer
vollautomatisierten Welt und so weiter
und die Menschen abhängig sind von KI es
ist verbindet sich ja nicht
uneingeschränkt mit positiven Vision bei
einigen Leuten ja aber bei sehr vielen
Leuten eben auch nicht was wir ja
eigentlich bräuchten während Bilder
einer positiven Zukunft ja stattdessen
wir haben ja schon mal darüber geredet
ne wenn man Klimawandel denken dann
versuchen wir uns nicht ein schönes Bild
auszumalen wie ist das wenn wir jetzt
alles richtig machen kriegen wir dann
die Welt hin ja sondern wir sehen
eigentlich immer nur der Zeiger klebt
seit Ewigkeiten auf fünf vor zwölf und
wahrscheinlich ist schon fünf nach 12
und das ist immer
Sozialismus ja also das ist ein bisschen
das Gefühl die Geschichte der Menschheit
ist eigentlich aus erzählt genau das
auf allen eben genau das war doch mal
andersrum ich meine jetzt auch in der
Philosophie auch es gab doch wir haben
doch wahnsinnig gelebt von Menschen die
Utopien entwickelt haben klar
an wen denkst du da
Thomas Moritz würde man anfangen bei der
kommt der Begriff her also Thomas moritz
war
ein tolles Phänomen er war Lordkanzler
und da Heinrich dem achten also diesem
viel schrötigen
Brutalo König der Frauen im Wesentlichen
durch Enthauptung los wurde
ja dann
Ärger mit dem Papst hatte und dann mal
kurz die anglikanische Kirche gegründet
hat seinen eigenen Verein aufgemacht und
so ein Auto grad wie er im Buch steht
und dieser Thomas Morus war ein ganz
feingebildeter Humanist mit sehr viel
Sinn für Humor auch was übrigens unter
humanistan ja so lateinische
anspielungshumor aber so Humor der so
aus dem Volk kam oder so ja das hatte
das hatte Thomas also durch Punkt Cäsar
wie diese
kennt den kennst du auch noch nee denke
im Lateinunterricht immer als Caesar sah
übersetzt dass der Hafen voll war ja
schickte er daneben okay es war so unser
peneler Humor okay das das meinst du
noch
genauer von Erasmus von Rotterdam und
den anderen Humanisten ja die also so
köstliche Drogerien da verzapfen aber
hat einfach mal gesagt wir nehmen alle
guten Ideen und treiben die auf die
Spitze so wie zum Augenzwinkern ja und
dann lässt er einen Seefahrer Rafael los
griechisch übersetzt der Lügen Erzähler
erzählen dass er das war ja die Zeit
Kolumbus hatte Amerika
entdecktuch die die Küste und jetzt
konnte man natürlich sagen ich als
e-fahrer bin jetzt hier und da und da
gewesen und so weiter und da gibt es im
Fernsehen Südamerika ist ein Raum Utopie
weißt du die Welt war noch nicht bekannt
genau man konnte sich also das Paradies
nach irgendwo als bereits realisiert in
der Welt erträumen ja was ja heute nicht
mehr geht aber damals gab es halt so
viel blinde Flecken und dann nicht mehr
sagen diese sein Handy ja schon Lügen
erzählen also der gebildete Zeitgenosse
wusste dass es ersponnen aber es hätte
ja sein können und da ist eine Insel mit
einer perfekten Gesellschaft drauf und
da funktioniert alles und im Grunde
genommen ist das sehr sehr nahe an einer
traumhaften bürgerlichen
rechtsstaatlichen Republik und ich meine
es überlegen jetzt Anfang des 16
Jahrhunderts ja also sowas nirgendwo
irgendwo in sichtbar Jahre leben die
Menschen auf dieser Insel was war die
Utopie die Utopie ist also es gibt keine
Ahnung und kein Reich alle gleich alle
haben ungefähr gleich viel ohne
gleichgemacht zu werden ja aber sie
haben Eigentum hat seine seine zentrale
Bedeutung verloren für die Leute ja
interessant die Häuser werden alle zehn
Jahre getauscht
ja das wirklich gesehen alle gleich aus
oder ja also er hat sich so ein bisschen
sieht das so wie genossenschaftshäusern
sich das vorstellen aber wenn man
überlegt was ist nachher alles für für
gruselige Gleichmacherei Utopien gab von
dem Geist ist es eigentlich nicht
beherrscht er gesagt die materiellen
Dinge da müssen wir uns da nicht lange
drum kümmert es gibt zum Beispiel keine
Anwälte mehr weil es gibt keinen Grund
mehr sich zu streiten ja ein gutes
Eigentumsfragen jeder hat genug ja also
die leben alle Mittelschicht Leben okay
damalige Zeit der deutschen vorstellbar
damals lebten 95% der der der
Gesellschaft in London in in den
Winterstar Armut und so weiter waren
waren Bauern in quasi Leibeigenschaft in
England und so weiter und so weiter also
unsere Mittelschicht Utopie jeder hat
wirklich ausreichend und sowas woher
kommt das Geld hatten die Leute keine
Angst vor der Gleichmacherei weil jeder
hätte ja viel mehr gehabt als die Leute
als die Leute sonst hätten woher kommt
das Geld weil alle sehr gerne arbeiten
ja und jeder nach seiner Befähigung
arbeiten kann ja also ein durch und
durch positivistisch ist Menschenbild
positives ja genau durch und durch
positive Menschenbild was dahinter steht
oder ist das alles also wirklich
großartig und ja und dafür hat man ihn
auch gemacht
ja genau
weißt du das ist völlig verrückt also
man passt ein bisschen aufeinander auf
das war die Idee ja und man tauscht ein
bisschen und hilft sich gegenseitig
genau freundliche Nachbarn so und man
tauscht so garantives arbeiten das hat
weißt du wo es wo diese Utopie
tatsächlich wo ich die erlebt habe in
Grünland okay ich habe das oft gehört
wenn wenn in so einem kleinen Dorf du
hast eine kleine Holzhütte und dann bist
du länger weg und dann kann sein dass da
eine andere drin wohnt heuer okay und
die hat dann einfach jemand genommen und
das ist dann aber auch kein großes
Problem
[Musik]
Frauen so familiär so unter guten
Freunden geteilt werden das das ist auch
so ein Klischee dass wir immer so mit
uns rumschleppen das ist sozusagen das
ist ein ganz kompliziertes Ding du musst
dir immer klar machen ne wir reden über
winzige kleine Gemeinschaften die
vollkommen isoliert voneinander leben
also wenn du die polarin z.B nimmst in
in nordgründet um in der Schule ja heute
die wurden ja dann umgesiedelt weil die
Amerikaner dort ihre Militärbasis
aufbauen wollten ins heutige Kanak ein
schlechter Ort weil windiger Ort es war
es ist kein Platz wie der alte es war
und ist ehrlich gesagt ein ziemlich Gott
verlassener Ort da Leben
800 900 Menschen und
wenn du dann so abgeschieden lebst
früher war das ja noch viel viel viel
weniger dann ist natürlich die Frage
woher kommt das frische Blut irgendwann
das heißt wenn wenn dann irgendwie der
eine Jäger von weit weit weg mal zu
Besuch kam und so weiter
dann passierten da Dinge aber das folgte
ganz strengen Regeln das hatte nichts
mit Sodom und Gomorra und irgendwelchen
Orgien zu tun dafür Regeln es gab ganz
klar Tabu das Wort Tabu wurde dann auch
eingesetzt Codes Tabus Dinge die man
nicht macht aber eben auch Dinge die man
macht die nicht dem bürgerlichen Moral
verständnisvollen Hygiene
entsprechend unterwegs bist ist er ein
Material hat sind eher Frauen die das
sagen können die suchen also wenn dann
so ein attraktiver junger Mann wie du
dann kommt in so ein kleines Dorf bis
heute würde ich sagen da müsstest du
damit rechnen dass die ein oder andere
Frau dir sehr klar zu verstehen gibt
dich finde ich gut dann könnte passieren
dass jemand daneben sitzt und sagt kein
Problem finde ich in Ordnung genau der
sieht mehr ähnlich
ja ja genau das ist sehr interessant
Thema gewesen wie die sexuelle Frage
geregelt wird wusste ich nicht ja also
weil es gibt ja am Anfang diese Raum
Utopien also wie Morus Utopia oder
Tomaso Campanella der Sonnenstaat das
ist da ist eine riesen
Architekturentwurf in so sieben Ringen
ja
teilt sich die Stadt ein und das ist
aber alles ziemlich so brutaler so
jesuitenmäßig streng und so Frances
Bacon Hannover
von Peter Thiel im Silicon Valley träumt
ja eine eigene Insel wo sich alles der
Technik glaube
Optimierungsmodell genau
und dann kommt irgendwann die Zeit
Utopien das heißt also wenn klar ist die
Welt ist weitgehend und solche Inseln
gibt es nicht und so dann verlagere ich
den idealen Staat in die Zukunft
und ich habe einmal schon mal davon
gesprochen aber es ist ein tolles Thema
also vor Marx ja gab es schon und Schal
vor je hat sich ideale menschliche
Gemeinschaften ausgedacht ja also
ähnlich versucht wie die Inuits mit
neuen Normen kurz und so weiter ohne
Sodom und Goa aber ohne die menschliche
Natur in irgendeiner Form zur gewaltigen
zu beeinträchtigen wie könnten ideale
Gemeinschaften aussehen weil der hatte
die Theorie für die damalige Zeit
revolutionär wir reden jetzt so von
18820 gesagt das größte Problem ist doch
letztlich dass die Menschen in der
bürgerlichen Gesellschaft ihre Triebe
permanent unterdrücken müssen wir sind
voller angestauter Leidenschaften die
wir nicht ausleben können und wenn der
Mensch gegen seine Leidenschaften lebt
lebt er gegen seine Natur falsch Leben
und was wirst du eifersüchtig nein
ekliger Charakter ja und das zu
verhindern wenn jeder seine
Leidenschaften so ausleben könnte wie es
ihm entspricht
dann wird der Deal hier aufgehen sicher
also hatte sich überlegt okay
aus dem griechischen Wort fahrlangs
Schlachtreihe Geschlossenheit und aus
dem Gedanken des Klosters ja hermetisch
abgeriegelte Anlage wo man miteinander
klarkommen muss entstehen die Balance
terien das sind Kunstform also aus
monasterie ja und aus Fahrland das heißt
wo alle sozusagen aus dem gleichen
Interesse Kommune
und da werden die Leidenschaften so
geregelt dass also prinzipiell es gibt
keine bürgerliche Ehe in dem Sinne es
gibt eher ähnliche Gemeinschaften und
der Status wird signalisiert das heißt
also kannst den Status ich bin auf der
suche ja und eben Abenteuer zugetan du
hast den Status äh ich bin gerade Mutter
muss mich in erster Linie um meine
Kinder kümmern ja und so gibt es
sozusagen für jeden Status du bist ein
Code so dass man weiß das Gleichgesinnte
sich problemlos irgendwie treffen können
also es ist im Grunde genommen Kinder
ohne Digitalisierung
einfach damit der ohne Smartphone ohne
Smartphone genau ja und sich also
vorgestellt dass das irgendwie so
funktioniert und auch Arbeiten jeder
nach seiner Neigung und zusammen und so
weiter und dann hat er sich gedacht das
müsste man machen so um mal so 1000 1500
Leute in so eine Gemeinschaft und das
wäre so überzeugend das würden sich alle
anderen von überzeugen lassen und
irgendwann wurde ganz Frankreich und die
ganze Welt auszahlungsterien bestehen
und es gäbe keine Kriege mehr
gegeneinander weil es gibt nichts was
man erobern will jeder ist zufrieden mit
dem Wasser hat diese erfahren hast du
ihn sehen pompös aus die sehen also
jetzt nicht so Boris sie zu bürgerlich
aus wird genossenschaftsweise bei ihm
die Franzosen hat er sich da was
aufgemalt dass sie so aus wie im
Jesuiten Staat in Paraguay also richtig
so schnörkelige überhaupt
einen kleinen für jedermann auch
Reichtum du kannst so viel anhäufen wie
du willst besitzen darfst du wie du
willst aber du kannst nicht ausbeuten
ja das heißt also es gehört schon alles
der Genossenschaft das ist ja die
marksidee eigentlich
null Problem mit Besitz und Eigentum ja
also
ja selber war gerne eine teure Flasche
rein getrunken und wir werden ja wenn da
wenn er nicht abhängig gewesen wäre von
von Engels selber hat hier eigentlich
fast kein Geld verdient der hätte
prunkvoll gelebt da wäre dieser Salon
max ist oder so gewesen vom Sozialismus
singt und dabei Champagner trinkt ja ja
genau
der hatte also nichts von von Paul Pott
oder von WoW oder irgendwie sowas ne
links predigen und rechts Leben hat
gesagt du kannst du kannst einen Besitz
alles anhäufen du darfst es aber nicht
auf Kosten anderer also Wirtschaften
also durch die Arbeitsleistung anderer
der Marxismus war halt bei die Utopie
die Ausbeutung loszuwerden und wenn man
sich den jungen magst anguckt der ganz
stark von diesem scheiß vor je geprägt
war okay ja nur schlecht geredet hat wie
über alle andere Konkurrenz also die mus
alle erschossen werden alle genannte das
utopischen Sozialismus okay was er
selber machte war wissenschaftlich also
das sollte keine Utopie sein magst
mochte das Wort Utopie nicht ne aber als
er zum ersten Mal mit mit Engels da
waren sie jung ja da träumten sie davon
ihr eigenes Ding aufzuziehen sozusagen
ihr philosophisches Startup aufzuziehen
gesoffen wie die Löcher ja gut gelebt
und in der Zeit haben sie zum ersten Mal
definiert was Kommunismus ist und da
sagt Max Kommunismus ist wenn ich
morgens Schafe Hüte mittags Fischen gehe
und abends Bücher kritisiere ohne doch
je hörte Fischer oder kritiker werden zu
müssen also ich muss nicht ein Leben
lang die selber einförmige Tätigkeit
machen wie in einer kapitalistischen
Gesellschaft sondern ich kann mich
optimal selbst verwirklichen also würde
ich sagen doch dein Buch Titel ja genau
und ich würde sagen das hat ja
Kapitalismus in den reichen
Industriestaaten für die Jugend von
heute relativ gut realisiert neben ihm
sagt das darauf einstellen nicht ein
Leben lang das gleiche zu machen
weil die die Jugend am Prenzlauer Berg
die in den von ihren Eltern finanzierten
Häusern lebt ich meine mit Jugend jetzt
auch 30-Jährige und so weiter mit
kleinen Kindern was machen die Projekte
ja jetzt mal ein paar Jahre da und dann
da und dann da das kommt der Utopie ja
schon ziemlich lange
das übrigens interessanter würden die
jetzt antworten ja siehst und das ist ja
genau unser Problem diese Unsicherheit
die da drin ist wir sind ja sozusagen
die Generation Projekte wir haben ja gar
keine Verlässlichkeit mehr das war ja
bei euch anders und so weiter und ihr
ihr Boomer ihr bumers ja also wir du
bist gerade noch bumer oder 64 okay der
der der der Auflagen stärkste Jahrgang
wirklich
war der absolute
Highlights ich weiß es nicht aber wir
waren überall mit 45 Kindern in der
ersten Schuljahr ich finde heute in der
hundertsten Lukas mal netterweise einen
kleinen für uns nehmen Lukas
guck mal wie viel
Prechts da draußen rumlaufen können
ungefähr ja der auflagenstärkste jagen
das war die ja ich bin glaube ich gerade
schon offiziell raus du bist der anfangs
ja der kam danach ja der Anfang des
pillenknicks gut jetzt muss man sagen
ich hatte diese Verzögerung ja durch
durch meine Jugend in den Südtiroler
Bergen natürlich ist das bei uns ankam
das hat noch ein bisschen gedauert wobei
mein Vater die waren 14 Kinder zu Hause
14 Kinder
in Apulien oder Kalabrien groß geworden
wir hatten sozusagen eine Idee davon
da geht noch was während die Generation
die da mit Projekten im Prenzlauer Berg
sitzt wie von dir gerade geschrieben die
hat das Gefühl er geht nicht so aber was
willst du denn ich meine entweder du
hast diese Freiheit für egal es gibt von
euch gibt es
1,1,36 Millionen 1,36 also ungefähr so
viel wie Einwohner in München ist ja
unvorstellbar Wahnsinn also München hat
nur ihr vollgemacht genau also wenn man
alle in meinem Alter nehmen würde wäre
in München komplett gefüllt ja runter
mit reiner Langhans Kommune 1 nein aber
jetzt ist er muss fragen was willst du
eigentlich also heute hast du die ist
die die Unsicherheit ist ja nur deswegen
größer aber die Freiheit größer ist und
wir haben doch immer mehr dafür gekämpft
in dieser Gesellschaft
freiheitsspielräume zu erweitern und du
musst nicht dein Leben lang die gleiche
Arbeit mehr machen es ist ein legitimer
Gesellschaf
einerseits ist das auch ein großer zu
gewinnen will aber keine Rose ohne
Dornen dann musst du halt mit einer
größeren Unsicherheit aber das meine ich
Richard wann uns das abhanden gekommen
diese wir reden ja im Kern ja jetzt auch
eine Utopie klingt so hoch tragen wir
reden ja eigentlich über den Blick aufs
Leben auch über Zuversicht darüber reden
wir doch eigentlich ne wann ist uns
sozusagen dieser Optimismus abhanden
gekommen wird schon werden ich habe
neulich Arnold Schwarzenegger zugehört
der es fand ich total gut auf die Frage
hatten Sie jemals eigentlich einen Plan
B sagte ich hasse Plan B und ich hatte
nie einen Plan B und hat er genau
erklärt warum Plan B für ihn nie ein
Thema war weil er meinte wenn du
anfängst über Plan B nachzudenken dann
hast du keinen richtigen Fokus mehr auf
Plan ah ja und ein bisschen ist das
deine Geschichte du hast auch alles auf
deine Karte auf eine Karte gesehen aber
ich sage nee aber ich weiß noch nicht ob
ich einen Plan hatte also ich würde
sagen ich hatte eine ungefähre
Vorstellung wo ich meinte was meine
Talente liegen dass ich 18 oder 19 war
und das hat ausgeschlossen dass ich zu
einer Bank gegangen bin oder zur
Stadtverwaltung oder auch immer
und so einen richtigen Plan so
strategisch gehe ich das jetzt an und
dann baue ich hier mal das auf ne und so
weiter das hatte ich eigentlich auch
aber das ist glaube ich das was er meint
meinte einfach nur sozusagen der Wille
jetzt was zu wollen wie genau weiß ich
nicht und Plan B was soll Plan B ich
habe gar keine Ahnung was das sein soll
sondern wirklich und das setzt es ja
voraus so voller Zuversicht und
Optimismus rein im Plan ah ich ich habe
ein anderes Beispiel für dich aus der
Welt der Technik ja als du erinnerst
dich das menschliche Genom das war so um
den 90er Jahre herum ja 90 glaube ich
sogar wurde sozusagen überlegt wie
können wir das menschliche genomen
komplett Entschlüsse human proje genau
richtig wie lange wird das dauert und
ich das kam so um 2008 sehr interessant
und wurde 1990 gesagt
schaffen wir nicht weil
frühestens 2005 und so weiter weil die
Rechner die Rechenleistung die wir jetzt
haben die die wir bräuchten tausendmal
mehr Rechenleistung um überhaupt bis
2005 fertig zu werden das war das
einfach fertig waren wir 2002 ja drei
Jahre einfachste von der Welt war die
Steigerung der Rechenleistung so das
heißt
also wir wir hatten klar vor Augen wird
nicht funktionieren ein bisschen wie die
Situation jetzt dass wir eingangs
besprochen haben geht nicht geht nicht
geht auch alles nicht und die haben Sie
einfach die Arbeit gemacht und plötzlich
was drei Jahre früher fertig sind dann
kann man sagen einfach weil sie einfache
Probleme löst die Probleme die wir heute
haben die gehen nicht weg dadurch dass
einer eine gute Idee hat und dann
realisieren wir das und dann zack smarte
Lösung und weg ist es sondern im Grunde
haben verschiedene lösen ein Problem
aber immer auf Kosten das neue Probleme
entstehen
und da hat sich dieser dieser Fatalismus
irgendwie eingeschlichen dass die
Probleme von dem wir heute stehen und
das ist der Unterschied zu früher zu
groß sind
in den 50er 60er 70er Jahren gab es ja
auch Probleme muss ein neues
Rentensystem geschaffen werden
Deutschland musste seine seine
wirtschaftsperspektive erst nach Westen
ausbreiten dann Ostverträge nach Osten
braucht er also neue neue Räume von
importieren exportieren so dann
gesellschaftliche Probleme wie die 68er
Geschichte das die katholische
Sexualmoral die an die Stelle des
Hakenkreuzes getreten war also das
christliche Kreuz ersetzte das
Hakenkreuz als chefideologie und gab den
jungen Leuten eigentlich keine Luft zum
Atmen mehr das waren sich anstauen des
gesellschaftliches Problem so und dafür
brauchte man nicht wo die Dutschke
meinte eine Welt Revolution ja sondern
mehr sexuelle Freiheit mehr Rechte für
die Frauen ja
bürgerrechtsbereich wurde erweitert und
dann ging das wieder aber
innerhalb von Deutschland realisieren
konnte und die in den anderen westlichen
Ländern auch national geregelt werden
konnten übrigens überall zur selben
dieselben Sachen also das was ich
Probleme mit der Jugend was ist in
Deutschland gab oder umgekehrt das
Problem der Jugend mit dem Nazi Vätern
auf der anderen Seite das gab es auf
ähnliche Form auch wenn die Väter keine
Nazis waren in den anderen Länder auch
dass er der klassische Generation der
damaligen Zeiten das waren aber alles
der konnte man als als Politiker noch
und daher gehört wahrscheinlich auch die
Größe der wie die Brands und so weiter
auf dem nationaler Ebene noch halbwegs
aber die die die Dinge vor denen wir
jetzt stehen also die ökologische
Geschichte
man kann gar nichts machen nee aber
dieses Gefühl der Ohnmächtigkeit
gegenüber dem Problem das ist was neues
du ich verstehen Gedanken und du hast
auch total recht ich will aber trotzdem
noch mal sagen nur ein anderes kleines
Beispiel anführen schau dir mal den
Zustand der deutschen Autoindustrie an
wir sind also gerade diese Tage mich mal
mit Audi beschäftigt audi hat ein
einziges ich glaube der Q4 ist es
wirklich erfolgreiches Auto so im
chinesischen Markt und deswegen dort ein
riesiges Problem also das Problem von
von Audi als Marke ist ist nicht dass
sie nicht tolle Autos im Programm hätten
das Problem ist dass sie nur ein richtig
gut akzeptiertes E-Auto in China
verkaufen das ist der Problem das heißt
wo die Reise dahin geht dass wir das
gestalten müssen das ist ganz klar in
Richtung E-Mobilität geht wenn du als
Autokonzern erfolgreich sind das ist
alles völlig klar mir fällt dann im
Henry Ford rein
das legendäre Modell tja genau das erste
Auto das vom Fließband gekommen ist das
Vorgängermodell und das mal angesehen
das Modell s glaube ich ja lustig ne
denkst an Tesla das Modell Sack war kein
anderes Auto es war das exakt gleiche
Auto der einzige Unterschied war das
Modell Tee also das
ist
denkst du den Preis und ich glaube 700
oder 800 $ hast damals viel viel
150 also halbiert
es war der Erfolg das war die Vision das
war das ganze Ding und wenn du dir jetzt
mal überlegst welche Diskussionen wir
für Küche behandlungskräfte da sind wir
sagen immer weitermachen weiter bloß
nicht aber nochmal Technologie reden und
Automobilindustrie was ist denn
eigentlich die Utopie dass wir in der
Lage sind E-Autos eines Tages so günstig
zu bauen eines schnellen Tages wie die
Chinesen jetzt ich würde sagen erstmal
das oder für die Utopie die
Automobilindustrie nicht mehr zu
subventionieren und etwas anderes zu
finden was anstelle des Autos tritt denn
beim Bergbau haben wir viel zu lange ich
weiß gar nicht vorstellen was da alles
an Geld reingegangen ist das hätten wir
damals immer alles schön in die
erneuerbaren Energien stecken stimmt
also die Frage ist ja
versuchen wir hier einen toten Gaul
durchs Ziel zu reiten
müssen wir nicht rechtzeitig sozusagen
fragen was wird denn ja wenn die Zeit
des des deutschen Automobils
möglicherweise vorbei ist was wird denn
dann die neue Schlüsselindustrie aus
Deutschland sein was können wir jetzt
noch nichts weniger als das steht gerade
zu Debatte ich würde sagen dass das zu
Debatte steht weil ich meine die
Vorstellung dass wir im in China 40
Prozent der Autos verkaufen ist nicht
mehr konkurrenzfähig sind und dass die
Chinesen mit sehr sehr günstig
produzierten und sehr guten E-Autos den
Weltmarkt überschwemmen das ist ja nur
nicht irgendwas was man böse irgendwo
dran malt sondern etwas was ganz
unmittelbar vor der Haustür steht wie
weit die hat gerade die
Marktführerschaft von VW insgesamt
einen guten Grund warum es in zehn
Jahren noch eine deutsche
Automobilindustrie die international
konkurrenzfähig ist neben sollte naja
ich
also das meine ich doch also wie
Leistungs dann ständig so abseitige
Debatten ja wir pumpen das dann auf zu
einem riesen Ding zu einer Glaubensfrage
ob jetzt elektrisch oder mit Verbrenner
fahren und sehen halt mal dabei zu wie
woanders diese Zukunft einfach schlicht
und ergreifend gestaltet werden wird
einfach gelebt gemacht die Leisten sich
nicht 20.000 Schleifen extra noch mal
darüber zu diskutieren warum dann doch
der Verbrenner das coole Ding ist das
kann man alles betrauern und es ist auch
alles nicht schön
Technologie Deutsch zu erhängen aus
emotional nachvollziehbaren Gründen an
ihrer glorreichen Vergangenheit ja ja
also das ist aber die vergangen ich
meinte damit die Vergangenheit seit dem
50er Jahren
Vergangenheit und so weiter Zeitalter
des deutschen Ingenieurs ja wir waren da
nicht mehr militärisch die große Macht
aber wir wurden wirtschaftlich in
kürzester Zeit eine Welt macht und
deswegen ist das Auto ist der Mythos der
deutschen seit fünf Jahren deswegen
zeigt sich daran auch so viel festlich
und du kannst daran so viel ablesen auch
über dieses diese Beharrungskräfte die
ist da immer weiter gibt und
abschließend gefragt Richard ich meine
du tauschst dich ja nun auch viel aus
mit mit Leuten aus der Wirtschaft und so
weiter
hast du das Gefühl dass dass dieses neue
andere denken dass wir jetzt dringend
brauchen dieses wieder verliebt sein ins
gelingen und ins gestalten
dass das langsam sozusagen sich auch
gesellschaftlich wirklich Bahn bricht
oder oder werden wir noch in 10 Jahren
Verbrenner erhalten Plakatieren ohne
dass ich was gegen den Verbrenner haben
ich sag nur du hast jetzt eigentlich
eine listige Frage gestellt weil erst
hast du gesagt viele Kontakte in die
Wirtschaft was die Wirtschaft anbelangt
würde ich sagen es gibt natürlich beides
ne es gibt große Firmen Lobbys und
Bremser
aber es gibt auf der anderen Seite
gerade durch die Kreativität des
Mittelstandes die ja nicht über Nacht
verloren gegangen ist die ja immer noch
da ist jeden Champions die wir haben so
weiter also diesen Optimismus und diesen
Aufbruchsgeist den haben wir in unserer
mittelstandskultur auch bei einigen
wenigen größeren Unternehmen haben wir
das wir haben ihn viele viel weniger in
der Politik und das liegt daran dass die
Politik das gebranntere Kind ist aus dem
Gründen die ich vorhin genannt habe wenn
du wenn du als Visionär auftrittst wenn
du eine Firma führst passiert hier
nichts dann werden die Leute im
Zweifelsfall sagen hier da haben wir
doch mal wir haben doch auch visionäre
und so weiter aber eben als Politiker
bedeutet Visionär zu sein Dinge anders
zu sehen als sie bislang mehrheitlich
gesehen wurden und auf der Ebene ist der
Angst Stillstand riesengroß ist nicht in
der Wirtschaft zu groß ist in der
Politik so groß und die spannende Frage
wäre und das würde ich dich ja gerne mal
fragen ja wenn ein Ruck durch die
Politik gehen muss im Hinblick an mehr
an sich glauben mehr zu wagen und was
weiß ich was was glaubst Du könnte man
tun oder welche konstruktive Rolle
könnten die Medien spielen weil das
spielt natürlich eine Rolle ne die Angst
von Medien angefeindet
ich glaube tatsächlich dass wir uns dass
wir das a viel mehr einfordern müssen
auch so im direkten Gespräch also Leute
dann auch wirklich zu fragen okay sie
haben uns jetzt sehr wortreich erklärt
wogegen sie sind aber sagen Sie uns
bitte mal wofür sie sind das versuche
ich auch immer wieder und das könnte ich
immer beweisen der Sendung machen eine
reine wofür Sendung wo das Wort nicht
verändern genau und und das andere ist
natürlich ich glaube schon dass dass wir
einfach hart dran arbeiten müssen
sozusagen dieses dieses nicht zum
Programm werden zu lassen ja das ist vom
politischer Seite die Aufgabe und unsere
Aufgabe ist es und darum bemühe ich mich
zumindest immer nach nachdem was ich
darunter verstehe das immer wieder zu
entschlüsseln und zu dekodieren und
sozusagen in dem Punkt die die die
Floskel und die Stanze einfach
einzutreten weil man nicht durchgehen
lassen kann das Leute mit solchen
allgemeinen Plätzen dann einfach so
davon kommen sondern mit dieser er sagt
doch mal konkret was du jetzt ganz genau
was ist deine Quelle und wo willst du
eigentlich hin und wenn man wenn man das
systematisch machen dann habe ich schon
das Gefühl dann dann bewegt sich da auch
immer mal was und hast du ich habe ja
häufig dieses Gefühl wir hatten jetzt
einige Jahre die für die Utopie gar
nicht so schlecht waren wir haben ja in
Lüneburg manchmal im Jahresrhythmus
utopie-konferenzen
gemacht und es ist interessant wie viele
Leute mit interessanten Ideen für die
Zukunft kommt natürlich ist vieles
unausgegoren aber am Ende ja und sei es
ein homöopathischer Teil der von dieser
Idee der kann immer noch die halbe Welt
von denen das geht natürlich oft nicht
so einfach wie sich die Urheber von
Utopien das Vorstellen viele wissen das
ja auch ja aber ein richtig guter
starker Gedanke wenn der sich auch nur
zu 10% am Ende realisiert kann sehr viel
gewonnen sein richtig und ich habe jetzt
leider seit dem russischen Überfall auf
die Ukraine so das Gefühl wir kommen in
so eine Restaurants rein so eine ganz
schlechte Zeit für Utopien na dass du
die Gespenster von früher kommt zurück
ter Material Kriege und so alles Sachen
wo wir gesagt haben mit ihrem nun
wirklich im Global Village Inflation 21
Jahrhundert
also Kriege gehören nicht mehr in unsere
Welt Inflation darf nicht mehr in unsere
Welt gehören auch viele andere Sachen
dass man also mit dem billigen
Restaurant Timo noch punktet und so
weiter kann also eine aufgeklärten
Gesellschaft nicht mehr gehen plötzlich
das Gefühl so alles geht so
und wie fängt man das ab ja und
vielleicht kriegen wieder in die andere
Richtung
vielleicht letzter Gedanke ist es die
Idee dieses
sozialexperiments das irgendwann mal in
London gegeben hat also sozusagen nicht
die ganze Zeit Leuten von oben nach
unten so paternalistisch zu sagen was
auf wir wissen genau was gut ist für
euch ihr Dummerchen sondern den Leuten
selber mehr zuzumuten diese Kraft die
Kreativität die in jedem von uns letzten
Ende steckt wirklich wieder zu
aktivieren es gab einen interessantes
Experiment 13 Obdachlose schwierige
Typen die das ganze Jahr nur für Stress
gesorgt haben Behörden beschäftigt haben
die Polizei beschäftigt haben die Justiz
beschäftigt haben man hat mal
ausgerechnet dies allein diese 13 Leute
haben den Staat da muss an die 400.000
450.000 Pfund pro Jahr gekostet und dann
radikaler Schnitt zusammen was auf wir
geben euch jetzt einfach 3000 Pfund
jedem von euch stellen wir euch zur
Verfügung macht damit was immer ihr
wollt und alles andere stellen wir ein
wir kümmern uns darum nicht mehr
quasi bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen das
große überraschende Ergebnis ist dass
das funktioniert hat für einen großen
Teil von diesen Leuten die dann wieder
anfingen ihre Familien zu besuchen die
anfingen plötzlich wieder in eine Arbeit
zu kommen die interessanterweise mit
diesen 3000 Pfund die sie dann zur
Verfügung hat noch sehr sehr sparsam
umgegangen sind wenn du auf der Straße
lebst dann weißt du wo du Geld sparen
kannst und überlegst die ganz genau
wofür du Geld ausgibst und wofür nicht
also die Lehre daraus das klingt wie so
ein schönes romantisches Experiment und
am Ende sind alle glücklich aber die
Lehre daraus ist ich glaube wir sollten
manchmal ein bisschen mehr uns
gegenseitig also auch die Politik ihren
Bürgern Vertrauen Vertrauen jetzt könnte
man ja auch noch zweites ein deutscher
Mann originelles Gedankenexperiment
sagen und sagen das Parlament in
Deutschland verpflichtet sich dazu eine
halbes Jahr lang keinen nicht zu
gebrauchen ja also dem politischen
Gegner nicht zu sagen dass er nicht tun
soll sondern quasi nur positive Aussagen
darüber was man will zu machen dann wird
für die AFD in das vielleicht ist die
einzige Möglichkeit die Partei noch zu
entzaubern möglicherweise gut guter
Gedanke vielleicht können uns auch sowas
mal einige ich sag's demnächst mal vor
Richard macht das ja ja
danke dir ciao
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pot
Stars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]